[موسيقى]
مساء الخير عبر السياسي والمفكر تكتشف
المجتمعات لكن الفنان واهني هنا الفنان
المثقف والبلتزم والواعي اشبه بفيلم
وثائقي حي لتاريخ ميلاده ولمسيره مجتمعه
تشعر معه انك تلامس تاريخ بيديك تعيش
احداثه وتندمج بشكل ساحر مع بيئته وهذا ما
تشعر به تماما مع عائله الديدان في الكويت
الاب غنام والابن سليمان انت لا تجري
مقابله مع موسيقين بارزين فقط بل تركبوا
البحر مع الكويتيين في القرن التاسع عشر
تجول في قراهم تحضر افراحهم تشاركهم اعمال
البناء وصناعه السفن والغوص بحثا عن
اللؤلؤ تطل بعينيك على البيوت وتشاهد
العجائز وهن يقومن بالحناء والغناء تشارك
الاطفال العابهم وهذيجهم تتوحد مع التاريخ
عبر الموسيقى لقب برنامج ديجان بترسانه
الايقاعات شعبيه لم يترك اهجوجه ولا
ايقاعا الا وجعل منه لحنا خالدا في
الذاكره ولد عن 43 في حي المرقاب وفي
مدرسه ملا مرشد تعلم القران في سن المبكره
وكان قدر الكثير من اساطير الموسيقى
الانطلاق من النص الاعذب والانقى والاعظم
اجازته لجنه الاستماع في اذاعه الكويت كم
ملحن مطلع الستينات ثم شق طريقه في مسارات
فنيه ملتصقه بالبيئه والبحر والصحراء
واستطاع بعد قريه فريده قياده عمليه
التحول بشكل لافتت مقدمه الفن الشعبي في
ابها حله تصدى لعمليه توفيق الفنون
الشعبيه فكانت الحصيله ارشيفا تاريخيا
للموسيقى في البلاد اسس فرقه التلفزيون
الكويتيه الاشهر في الخليج وقدم العديد من
الالحان لفرقه المسرح الشعبي وكان ابرزها
المسرحيه الشهيره علي جناح التبريزي وتاب
وقفه ثم وجد في عالم الاطفال والعابهم
ماده غنيه فقدم فيها ما لم يقدم من قبل
ومن بعد واخيرا كانت مسيره الابريتات
الخالده في الذاكره مثل مذكرات بحار والتي
شكلت البصمه الفنيه المميزه للكويت في
محيطها في حلقتين من المقابله نعيشوا مع
عائله الديدان الاب الغنام والابن الدكتور
سليمان نحاول تسجيله وتوثيقه هذه المسيره
الفنيه الزاخره مشاهدي الكرام اهلا ومرحبا
بكم
[موسيقى]
بلاش على الموسيقى
يامه فين انا شخصيه
عندي استعداد اتعلم اي شيء عندك شغف
بالضبط للسادس مع عبد الحميد الهواري مصري
والاستاذنا موفقته وكان سوري اول ما يبدا
يفتح المعركه يفتح المركز تلاقي مجموعه من
الشباب 20
واللي اخوان بعد ما تبدا الدراسه الخاصه
نادي السالميه عشان ندرس الشباب
الموسيقى بشكل عام الفن
مع الحب او الشباب الموسيقى العالم
[موسيقى]
شنو يعني هذا شغلتك ولا شغله ابوك ولا جدك
انت كل يوم واخذ العود ورايح المغرب
متى تحول الى محترف في هلا في العالم ابو
خالد انا بعتبر نفسي تقريبا
نص
وجيز النص وبعدين تقدم الاذاعه اول لحنين
المؤلفين معروفين استاذ خالد
للاسف المطرب ما
نجحنا جميله جدا
فبدات مرحله
الرموز ذيك المرحله ابو خالد رموز الفنيه
مثل الاستاذ احمد
هندوخي
وكان في مجموعه من الاخوان ابراهيم
رحمه الله
الاضافه الى اول سؤال
يعني
الفنان يوسف المهندس
ابو حسين جاسم سويت اكثر من منا العمل
اغاني عاديه اغاني وطنيه
من الايام
كان في العيد يمشي بالقليل وبعدين بدات
استاذ حسين جاسم ما شاء الله لهم ميول في
حب الغناء الشعبي حسين جاسم حسين جاسم
المعيز عليك السيد هذا هذه الاغاني
الاجتماعيه كلها صدى غير عادي عند الناس
واول مره تيجي شركه تطلب منها الصور
[موسيقى]
موجود والكتابات عن الفنون الشعبيه كانت
نادره للغايه حاولت البدايه لا تقرب من
البحاره لمعرفه اسرار هذه الفنون لكنهم
رفضوا استعنت من الفنان نجم الامير وايضا
الملاحق القدير يوسف منه وبعدين بدات تسجل
مع الفرق
في في تفاصيل ال ال الغناء بالنسبه
للبحاره مرتبط بالعمل
وتفاصيله مرتبطه بالعمل بعدين بدات تكتب
عن الاغنيات البحاره بدات تحدد الانواع
السنجني الاشياء هذه كل هذه التفاصيل كانت
مهمه صعبه خالص
الكبار
الراشد ابي يعني او الناس
[موسيقى]
اصول قديمه انها تحط القديمه وتمني عليه
جديد فتلاقي الناس كلها معتبرون كانه هو
هذا يعني وصله القديم بمعنى
سمعت ملكات محاره وسندباد هي الاشهر
فهي الموسيقى المقدمه وبعدين لما يدخل
المطرب الفصحى
البحرثه
الخليج مع الاستاذ
الشعبيه دونت الفنون ما هي خارطه الفنون
التراثيه اللي اللي عملتها
عاده في الكتب العربيه والمصاعدين العربيه
وخصوصا في المشرق العربي يعني لغايه همم
الكويت بس هو الخليجي المفروض احنا نكتب
مختلفه يهتمون
في
الغناء النغمي اكثر شيء نقم العود
والقانون وفي نعطالب جميل الى العربي
فلفل الميادين وفي الشوارع وفي الافراح
الالات الايقاعيه امطار حاله
الشكل لازم يدون وفي طبله لازم يكتب لان
يطول ثلاثه خطوط وبعدين
خط ثاني مختلف اذا كان بيستعملوه مثلا
عندي مجموعه من
التلوين بشكل غير مسلوق هذا كانت تمارس
لكن ما كانت
هذه الحقيقه هي الطريقه الوحيده لتدوين
الاخاء في الخليج
العربيه لا اعرف الدول الخليج هنا بالذات
محتاجين هذه الطريقه بالضبط عشان نفهم شنو
هذه الاغراء ابو خالد في كل الاعمار
اللاحقه ان تضمن كل هذه الانواع
كلها لحتى في الاوبريتات لاحقان في
الاغاني الوطنيه
واحب
الاخوان
[موسيقى]
المؤمرات النجوم
الغارقه
[موسيقى]
والجماعي يستخدم
والاستاذ خليفه العميري كان رئيس فرقه
الاميري بالاخير طبعا مات بعد ما توفي
المسجل
انواع من الموسيقى
فتميت اسماء السامري انواعه فنون خماري
انواع حتى ابحث عن الاسماء اخذ الاسم اكون
بعض الناس بس اخذ منهم الاسماء يقول والله
هو اسمائه
التفاصيل عند اهل السنه واحد يقول لا ما
في هذا كله
سامريه هذا سامري 30 تبينتها علميه ان هذا
سمير رباعي الاسامي ثنائي هذا اصبح قواعد
ولا قواعد
تختلف من الميزان 30 الميزان
يعني دونت معظم هذه الفنون حولتها الى الى
قواعد والى شيء يمكن البناء عليه
الصلاه والسلام الجزء الاول والجزء الثاني
في تفاصيل ما فيهم واحد كلهم في في
التراثيه وفي تفاصيل اللحم
النصر القديم الايقاع الاولى الطار الطبل
الطبل الثاني التصفيق الطاسه جميع هذه انا
كمسيقي جديد بامكاني ان اعرف
الوطن العربي حتى في الاجنبي حتى الاجنبي
[موسيقى]
يا حماده
عليكم
المربي الحقيقي فجاه الاطفال جاهزين حنا
بالتلفزيون الفنانه سعاد عبد الله ومعاها
مجموعه بعد طبعا الممثلين حتى الاستاذ
احمد الصالح اللي كتب
بس يا بحر هو اللي قاعد يعمل الظالم ومش
عارف بس الصوت داخل الستوديو الفنانه سعاد
عبد الله الشاعر
للاطفال بالضبط
مقدمه حقك ما يحضر الحقيقه اسمعك الا لان
كثير حفله على بدا تقريبا 25 او 30 سنه في
وزاره التربيه ليكون فيها اكثر من
منصقل الاطفال وبعدين تيجي بالاخير اللي
يجي بالاخير القصيده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اه ابو خالد حياك الله في مكتبك
الموسيقى والثقافه الموسيقيه الصوم
هذا المؤلف الرئيسي بالضبط
كثير في فنون الخماري انا جمعت هذه
الاسماء اللي ما كانت معروفه اساسا قبل ما
اجمعها في هذا الكتاب هذه الاسماء اعتبار
عن بعض اسماء المعروفه منها بس حاولت اخذ
التفاصيل منها وبعدين
كله تدوين والايقاع والموسيقى ههه يعني
ابو خالد بشكل عملي الان اي معزوفه همم
مقطوعه موسيقيه نقول على الربابه على
الطار على اي على خليجيه الان يمكن ان
يعزفها اي شخص بالعالم بس في شويه ملاحظات
بالنسبه للغناء الشعبي يعني همم
التعبير عن الجره بالضبط
والقوس يكون غير محدود غير الاغنيه
بقوه بخفه في هذه الاستراحات طبعا انا كنت
في وقت في الجامع كنت اجمع بينهم بس ابي
اعرض للناس من او بخصوص الفنانين بالذات
عشان يعرفون فان هذا الشيء انواع الفنون
هذه ما هي انواع ما هي الاسماء كنت اجمع
بينها يعني جرات الابواب هذه الجره هذه
المفروض يكون
على الاقل اللي بيسمع يعرف
ما هي الربابه يعني انا عملت شويه تفاصيل
عنها قبل ما احط الحانه وحبيت وصفه عنها
مقامها هي عباره عن متر واحد
بحدوده لكن المفروض
الحركات اللي كل من كل جمله
الجزء الثاني
الاغنيه الشعبيه بالضبط
نعرضها بشكل سريع ونمر
السامري غناء العام والخماري الخاصه
بس اهو اي واحد من الناس لكن المتخصص لانه
خلاص صعب لقاء وصعب الغناء
الفنون البحريه
لان الفنون البحريه فعلا انشائكه وطويله
عريضه طبعا وتحتاج الى كثير من التدوينات
الكتابه
الكويتيه يعني بدنا نعمل هذا مختصر
البحريه
عملها طويل
ووصفه صعب جدا لان فيها للكره وفيها
للنهامين وفيها
طريقه الايقاعات وازمز حال مال جهال يعني
على الاقل تكون بهذه على الاقل
البحري ننتقل ابو خالد الى واحده من اهم
المحطات في تاريخ الفن في الكويت وايضا من
اهم المحطات في تاريخنا عن الاوبريتات
الوطنيه
التي كانت علامه فارغه في تاريخ الموسيقى
ونتحدث ايضا عن فرقه التليفزيون هذه
الفرقه التي شكت حالها استثنائيه لكن ليس
هنا في الصومعه في مقر الفكر والعصف
الذهني انما في مقرها اساسا في المكان
الذي عقدت فيه هذه الاوبريتات بحضور ملوك
ورؤساء دول وقاده ووزراء ومثقفين وايضا 4
متذوق الفانوس حاضر حياك الله ابو خالد
حياك سلمان حياك الله
[موسيقى]
تحب تسمع لما تطلع تتمشى او تروح مشوار
طويل مثلا في السياره يعني يسمع بعض
الاشياء
هذه
الكلاسيك
واحيانا احب اسمع القران
القران بيعطي شيء من بدايه بدايه كانت مع
القران
غريبه معظم الفنانين الملتزمين لاحظ بخالد
انه بداياتهم تكون مع القران الكريم
قراءه تلاوه
سبحان الله القران فعلا ملهم على جميع
الاصيله
القران خلال
حتى عند الفنانين الملتزمين ابو خالد
المثقفين يعني عاده تكون بداياتهم
في لها ارتباط حقيقه معظم المطربين ال ال
البارزين والكلاسيكيين كانوا قراء
للقران يعني يجدون تلاوته
والحلو في القران في
فوائد الفنان بالذات لانه مخارج الافاق
وبعدين يضطر الواحد يعرف
تشكيل
اللي على
المفردات العربيه
يعني مثل
اللغه العربيه الكويت
ام كلثوم وفي حقيقه فيها ليله مراد في
اصوات جميله فريد الاطرش هذا كان اييي هو
افضل الثالث
بعض الفنانين او الموسيقي ابو خالد
يترفعون عن التراث ان التراث هذا شيء بسيط
وشيء شعبي انت دخلت فيها العالم الشعبي
وجعلت منها
الشعبيه والتراثيه هي المدرسه
في عمل ميزان فقط تلفزيون مع زميلي مرزوق
المرزوق
اغاني شعبيه
نغنيها بالبدايه بس لازم يكون لها شخصيه
غير الناس شبعانه من الشعبي
الشعبيه جمله مقدمه
الخام
[موسيقى]
تاريخ الموسيقى
داخل بنتكلم بالتفاصيل الله يطول عمرك
حاضر
امير امير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ابو خالد احنا نبي نعرف قصه الاوبريتات
شلون بدات فكره انتاجها متى بدات اول مره
مع منو تحديدا شنو كان التوجه اللي في
ذهنك في ذلك الوقت في خط وهويه هذه
الاوبريت انا كانت حقيقه في كنت اقتني
مجموعه من اسطوانات وخصوص
الرحباني بالاضافه الى ان في بعض الابراج
في العالم يعني لانك انت اللي نايم من
القراءه
كبير فاتمنى نلف على محلات الموسيقى
انا بدا الاستاذ بدر وما شاء الله يحفظ
المطالع اكثر الاغاني الاطفال بالاول يمكن
لعبه
سبسب اموت لاحد عنكبوت وهذه عباره كان
الاولاد يغني مع كره صغيره
للاطفال يلعبون
بالفريج او في الحاره وبعدين يجيء الشاي
يبقى رجل
بدات
الامريكيه
الفنانه الكبيره سعد عبد الله
ما شاء الله شخصيه
لابستها بالضبط طفله صغيره وك ده هو همم
باي شكل هي ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
المدينه
العلاقات القضايا المواضيع المشاعر
الازياء طريقه اللابات القهوه
المسؤولين يكون في معها عمل كل البنات
يشاركون في هذه الاحتفالات
فعلى كان عندي موضوع مشتغل فيه ولكن على
كل يوم
مذكرات بحر عجبني هذا الكتاب في المكتبه
محمد فايز واخذت هذا الكتاب عندي مخزون عن
الفنون البحر
المقامات
سمعنا الخليل
مدارس كل المدرسه عليها
المسرح الحركه همم الموضوع شكل الموضوع
بدايه
كلام همم نعات الرحلات بعدين داخل الهيرات
اللي هي مكان همم يا اخي استخرجوا منها
المحار للحصول على اللؤلؤ فبدات هذه
الاسلوب ودخلت معنا الحقيقه طالبه بس فنان
مميزه الصلاه
يا كويتي الى شواطئ الام
[موسيقى]
ين
نحن
نهجى
[موسيقى]
بك
امانه س
فينه على الساحل معظم تراثها وعرفها بحري
لكن الباديه والصحراء ايضا تمثل العمق لم
يركز عليه بشكل كبير باعتقادك ولا اخذ
نصيبه
صدق التاريخ
جره الربابه
والجماعه الاخوان لابسين او الشباب لابسين
لبس الباديه
تقريبا
اغاني الصوت وتركيبتها تختلف عنها او
يختلف عن غناء سامري
تختلف في اللبس في البيت الشعر وبعدين هي
تطور معنا هذا الكلام
طلع معانا الاستاذ
عبد الرحمن النجار وعمل عن الاشجار
معروف اللي مخلل
المخللنا في البيت شلون يكبرون عليه قبل
محرم
من باب السرور
في المدرسه
طبعا الكويت دوله حديثه الاستقلال تاريخها
طويل لكن الدوله في الخليج كانت حديثه
وكان في محاوله للسيارات هويه
حكم خلف الامر سياسه ما توجهات الدوله ام
كان عمل فني موسيقي ابداع بحث
[موسيقى]
نوع من انواع الوطنيه الوطنيه
بحث عن اقدم انواع بس
اعه بعض الجمل لتصبح الكره
الرجل بطريقه
سليمان يعني بعد ما طلعنا بره الوظيفه
وهذه المجموعه
يتناقلها الاجيال جيلا بعد جيل
حدث تغيرت الامور يعني المسؤولين اللي
كانوا معانا بالاول ما اسم مره في هذا
المجال لكن في تصوري انه نازل تلاقي واحد
مثل الخليج
وتلاقي مثلا مثلا
شاركنا الاستاذ يوسف
استاذ الاسلام
تبدا نكرف يعني الاعمال بس مم ننتظر هاي
المتر تقدمها الفرحه عشان نشوف الديره
كلها سعاده الله كانت هذه اغنيه جميله
كانت هذا اللي كان العمل كان ممتاز خصوصا
اصدقائي الفنانين ابراهيم عامر الجماعه
هذه واخوانه السعوديه والاخواننا اكثر
تاسست فقط التلفزيون بطلب من همم وزاره
العمل
وكيل وزاره التلفزيون
الف يمكن 79 79 كان اواخر 79
واخترنا من كبار الفنانين الاستاذ نجم
الاميري وكان خبير لانه هو اللي كان معي
على الفرقه البحريه
الاسماء الاشرطه لكن
تسجل بطريقه
عجيب غريب وجميل وكان انتشاره كبير جدا
لان حاولنا ان تكون في الفراش الهويه او
تكون مثل اي ف الفرق القادمه
من التليين عمل الاغاني وساعدون حيه
مجموعه من اخوان الشعراء والمؤلفين وطبعا
اولهم بدر بوليسي لانه على الموضوع همم
كلمه اسافر اخليك
لون الوان الغناء
يعني
[موسيقى]
هذا الموضوع
الان تحتضر التلفزيون
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله في معالي الوزيره
وزاره الاعلام
السيده الهويدي منير الهويدي عفوا وهو انا
شايف انه مهتمين
تعالوا شوفوهم لان الفرقه الحقيقيه
سالم سالم الفهد كان هذا بنفس الارض بس
يعرفون كابول ما تعمل حفله التلفزيون
امور مهمه الملابس الاماكن
الاضاءات
الاكسسوارات
يعني تشوفها الناس
تحتاج الى عناصر المهمه عشان تطلع فوق
الكامل شنو رايك باللي سواه الدكتور
سليمان
امتداد
هل تعتقد انه سليمان
استمرار لمشروعك الموسيقي الفني الثقافي
الملتزم ام تعتقد انه اتخذ مسار
مختلف اخر هو الحقيقه
نفس الرجل
والتاليف الموسيقى
لبنان
الدكتور سليمان
بدا يحب الايميل اللي جاب الفن الشعبي
والفنترات يعني بس احنا فيه
اغنيه عاديه كل عمل من الاعمال الشعبيه
كلنا حول الى نعم في التوسيع وفي تحديدا
الاصوات اذا كان القران وفي التصفيق
المقنن واذا او في الغناء والتمديدات
الجميله وخصوصا لما بدات
شارك اكثر من الفرقه العاديه يعني في
اوركستله معانيه يعني بعدين معانا بعد
مجموعه من الاساتذه مثل الاساتذه
حسن خليل استاذ علاء الشربيني السيده
فاطمه
هذه الاسره التي قدمت يعني فنان ملتزما
واصيلا الحلقه القادمه ستكون الدكتور
سليمان ابو خالد انا شاكر جدا لك ولا اريد
ان انهي هذه الحلقه بالاستماع لشيء منك
بعد هذا المشوار على على العود الجميل
اللي له تاريخ طويل ايضا الله معك مش
مشكله العود مال هذه الانسان يعني تقريبا
ست سنين ما استعملتها تلاقيه زعلان ههه
[موسيقى]
ابي شيء ثعالق في ذاكرتك
كثير
تقنيه الحديث
وتعلمت كيف اعمل السامبل لتركيب
العينات هتركبه وين من خلال الاورجوا على
الكمبيوتر
في الوقت هذا المشكله تغيرت
[موسيقى]
الاطار
جميله
ابو خالد احنا نشانا على على ما تركته من
الارث فني الحقيقه والثاني شرف كبير لي
اليوم ان اكون مع الاستاذ عدنان
قتلنا من اكثر من المنزل الى هنا احد
المعاقل الفنيه في الكويت
اذا كان في تغسيل
في هذه الاعمال
اه بيت الموسيقى عائله الديدان في الكويت
هذه الاسره التي اسهمت تساقط الكبيره
واستثنائيا في تاريخ الموسيقى وفي توثيقها
وفي صياغه ملامحها الحقيقيه الحلقه
القادمه مع الدكتور سليمان ديغان الى
اللقاء
مدينه الظنقه وخوفي
[موسيقى]
ولي
فيهن في الدنيا
[موسيقى]